quitte à quoi il a ici j'avais quoi un
divorce
non c'est un saint papy les autres
minerais vous salue bien bas gênerait
pas vraiment à la saisie le prénom de ma
famille à laquelle ces bombes à femmes
d'accueil or voilà jamais faire ça
pourquoi pas tout le monde le sait ces
machines pour plaider avec toi qui va
changer c'est pas grave il devrait
sortir avec quelqu'un qui a à la fois
dont je l'écris range en japonais ça va
vous a tâtonné si on est plein oui j'en
ai plein dans le dos j'en ai là je vous
avez quoi
gdl ah ouais ben barry vous alors vous
êtes la marque y en a marre mur dès qu
elle margouillats les arracher sans
déconner un margouillat sava ouais donc
vous avez un lézard ici c'est ton qui
est tatoué non non vous vous êtes vous
n'êtes pas un danger des plis mais pas
de toi là
[Applaudissements]
si vous n'êtes pas tatoué asséné plein
fouet c'est vrai je les fleurs des
papillons des corps médical licorne a
way that tatoué ouais c'est vous non non
au chic mais aussi où agen peau d'harry
5,6 sur la